although he loves mushrooms chemist
Stefan zebra no longer believes that the
next generation of antibiotics will come
from the forest increasingly the
substances that fungi produced to
protect themselves don't work against
resistant bacteria hizzle niknash they
are not looking for substances in fungi
we're pursuing a completely different
path looking for new chemical compounds
that don't work like traditional
antibiotic Evelyn zebras team is trying
to find out exactly what makes certain
strains of bacteria so dangerous the
microbes themselves don't make us sick
instead it's the toxins they emit and
bacteria produce more toxins in a
stressful environment benzi backed a nap
do you start to kill bacteria they'll do
everything they can to prevent it that's
where resistance comes from you do that
too if you were put on a life or death
situation you try to find a way out
that's what a bacterium does and that's
why we're trying to prevent the
bacterium from producing toxins such
stuff does it stops eating Jaeger stadia
expended I with us and so you totally
necessary Tokyo the starting point for
the new approach is a bacterial protein
that sets the machinery of toxin
production in motion this I did money
crew shopkins it's fine submit no son
that's zebras team has discovered a
substance that is able to block the
protein
so toxins are never released the
researchers have tested the compound in
both the petri dish and live animal
models the mazel tov was healed more
quickly because the bacteria were
stripped of their defenses we assume the
immune system was then able to eliminate
them bit by bit the abscess never grew
to significant size in other words this
mouse got better faster than a mouse
that hadn't received our treatment would
have an untreated mouse might not even
have survived an abscess like this as
you I didn't come as if my all kinds
food under the stash on us so the method
works at least in mice okay it's a son
man but Kent bacteria also grow
resistant to this treatment just like
with antibiotics you know gambia if
there is a simplified overview of what
happens when bacteria are eliminated by
an antibiotic will show that with red
crosses the whole turquoise this kind of
but it could be that one of the manages
to avoid destruction because you're
spontaneous mutation and has made it
resistant when Don can see this
bacterium can begin to reproduce and
spread and this new population you can
of course still produce and admit to
toxins that are so problematic for the
infection stall stall isn't diesel Pope
Tomata stand for the effects on our
approach does not allow resistance to
develop in the first place and these are
as tense and pickling as garnish that's
a common cillessen so then all the
bacteria are coated with a kind of
protective layer that prevents them from
producing toxin tiny so they remain
harmless the resistance that occurs with
antibiotic use never develops but him
antibiotic Oh
even if the chemist doesn't think the
woods can provide the answers to
antibiotic resistance in bacteria he
still enjoys searching here he saw if
I'm looking for mushrooms for dinner I
like the taste Steffen Seibert hopes
that within around a decade his method
of fighting bacteria could be used to
help heal patients with multi-resistant
infections